[Music]
welcome back so now I'm going to show
you one of my favorite numerical linear
algebra techniques to compute the SVD so
we've been talking about the the
singular value decomposition and now I'm
going to show you how to compute the
randomized singular value decomposition
so if your data actually does have low
rank structure meaning that X can be
approximated by only a few columns of U
and few columns of Sigma from the
singular value decomposition then we can
get away with using this randomized
linear algebra method the randomized SVD
to approximate these dominant our
columns of U and V much much more
efficiently without actually computing
the full SVD of X ok so I'm going to
walk you through the code I'm going to
show you how the our SVD actually works
and we're going to work this out on an
example okay so I think this is kind of
a fun example what we're gonna do is
load an image of Jupiter we're going to
compute the deterministic SVD so the
full-blown true SVD of X this is going
to take awhile so I might as well get it
running the full deterministic SVD of X
and then what we're going to do is we're
going to compute this randomized SVD
using an RSP decode that I generated and
we're gonna plot the original image the
true SVD reconstruction and the
randomized SVD reconstruction those
those three matrix reconstructions to
see how good the our SVD is is doing
okay let's see okay good so I computed
the full SVD use that ran now we're
gonna do the reconstruction we're gonna
take the first R columns of the true SVD
and compute that and then we're gonna
get the first R columns of the
randomized SVD and build that
approximation and we're gonna see how
accurate they are and I chose a target
rank of 400 because this image of
Jupiter can be well approximated with
about 400 rows and columns okay and my
original picture of Jupiter size of a
was 3200 by 2200 and 60 pixel image so
it's this massive mass
massive picture of Jupiter very
high-resolution I'm going to approximate
it with a rank 400 approximation with
both the deterministic SVD which is
expensive and the randomized SVD which
is cheap and we're going to see how
those compare so running this
reconstruction okay that's going to take
a little bit of time too to multiply all
of these rows and columns and recombine
into X from the SVD and then when that's
done we're going to plot the resulting
reconstruction of Jupiter using these
three these three methods good so here
we have our reconstruction and what you
have here on the left is on the left is
the true image this is the full image of
Jupiter so you can see all this great
detail the Great Red Spot and the kind
of instability region behind it you can
see the deterministic SVD here this is a
rank 400 approximation the very
expensive SVD approximation because
remember computing this SVD of a big
matrix does it is expensive you get away
with less data representation after
computing it so you get a compression
but it's expensive to find that
compression and then over here you see
the randomized SVD approximation and
then again very very faithfully captures
the the true structures in the data so
you can't tell the difference between
the randomized and the deterministic SVD
approximations except that the
randomized SVD was much much much faster
than the deterministic SVD okay and I
want to just go to the code real quick
so the our SVD code here basically takes
the same kind of arguments as the
regular SVD if you take the SVD of a
matrix X and you have some target rank R
ok we tell it what the target rank is so
that's a little different and then there
are these q and p factors which are for
power iterations and for over sampling
so q is the number of power iterations
and P is the over sampling factor and
I'll talk about that in a minute
and so this is all that there is to the
RSV D code it's super simple you
essentially take the data matrix X you
build a random projection matrix P okay
so x times this random projection matrix
P basically samples the column space of
X it multiplies and adds up all of those
columns and random combinations and
makes a skinnier version Z that should
have roughly the same column spaces X
okay so that's what Z equals x times P
is if you have power iterations then you
essentially run through and multiply by
X transpose X again and again and again
q times and that will decrease that'll
make the singular value drop off even
faster and give you better performance
but at the cost of a few more matrix
multiplications and then once we have
this sketched Z matrix which should have
roughly the same column space as X we
compute its QR factorization to get an
orthonormal basis Q we project our data
into that orthonormal basis Q to get
this little teeny tiny Y okay so we
project into Q to get Y and then we
compute the SVD of Y y equals u Sigma V
transpose these are the Y ones and the
Sigma and the V from this SVD are the
same as the Sigma and V from the
original x matrix and the u modes from
our higher dimensional data can be
easily combined as q times these low
dimensional u vectors so really quite a
simple algorithm here only a few lines
of code to compute this very fast
efficient randomized SVD my over
sampling factor P here it tells me if I
want to sample normally you sample our
columns of X through this random
projection matrix you sample our random
projections so this Z is an N by r
matrix and if you over sample you might
sample an extra 5 or 10 columns and you
get better and better performance so you
actually get rapidly faster convergence
of this algorithm even for just a few
extra columns in over sampling
okay so P and Q are kind of these knobs
that you can tune to make your
convergence faster good and then going
back to the code I just wanted to show
what happens if I take a random matrix X
and I compute its SVD so it'll have a
relatively slow singular value drop off
and then I want to show you what power
iterations does to make it have a better
roll-off of energy okay so I take this
big random matrix it's a thousand by a
hundred random matrix so it's it should
be low rank and what we have here are
the singular values at the original data
matrix in white and then what we've done
is essentially this power iteration so
for Q equals one to five we're going to
do one power iteration than another then
another than another and all this means
is we take our data matrix X and we
multiply it by X transpose times X Q
times okay and this over sampling factor
what it does is even after one iteration
of this power iteration the white
singular values which don't decay that
quickly and remember the our SVD relies
on a fast drop off of your singular
value so there really is a low rank
structure then even after one
application of the power iteration our
singular values are much much much much
much lower and they drop off much faster
and then iterating again and again and
again and again gives you this rapid
drop off in your singular value
distribution so this is just a cartoon
that shows you how over how power
iterations forces your singular value
spectrum to look lower rank than it
might actually be so that you could for
example approximate the first ten modes
more accurately using this method okay
so randomized SVD is an extremely
efficient and interesting technique to
compute this the singular value
decomposition when your data does have
low rank structure it's becoming it's a
relatively new technique but it's
becoming a cornerstone of numerical
linear algebra right now so in the
future this is going to be
standard practice if you have low ranked
data to compute the SVD not through the
deterministic method but through the
randomized method you know it has
tunable error bounds because of my
choice of q and p the over sampling
factor and it's really really easy to
code up just a few extra lines of code
to get this randomized SVD okay thank
you